هون معكم بواب انا مالكم ويب في جمهوريه
الكونغو الديمقراطيه هنا شمال مدينه كوما
الاف المدنيين يحملون ممتلكاتهم وهم في
طريقهم الى المدينه خوفا من تقدم متمردي
حركه الثالث والعشرين من مارس التي يقال
انها مدعومه من دوله رواندا
الطريق وقع الكثير من القتال والاشتباكات
وراينا العشرات والعشرات من الجنود
الكونغوليين باسلحتهم رشاشه وقذائهم
الصاروخيه وهم يسارعون باتجاه مدينه كوما
ما اثار موجه كبيره من الذعر في صفوف
المدنيين معظم هؤلاءهم بالاصل من سكان
مخيم كان يوريتشينو للنازحين
وعندما وهم يتقدمون باتجاه المدينه سرعوا
بحمل كل ما يمكن حمله من ممتلكاتهم
والنزوحه الى خارج المخيم لخشيتهم من سقوط
المنطقه في ايدي المتمردين رواندا تنفي
دعمها لحركه الثالث والعشرين من مارس التي
سبق لها سيطره على جوما عام 2012 قبل ان
تنسحب لاحقا منها بعد ان تمكن الجيش
الكونغولي من هزيمه مقاتليها لكنهم عادوا
للتمرد من جديد قبل نحو عام والناس هناك
تغادر المنطقه خوفا من عودتهم للسيطره
عليها من جديد